partir en Écosse pour progresser en
football et apprendre l'anglais c'est
l'objectif de
U Sport Academy la structure créée en
2011 membre de la Fédération écossaise
propose un programme de 9 mois en totale
immersion dans les villes de Glasgow et
d'Édimbourg c'est un peu entre
guillemets comme un centre de formation
ils sont des entraînement quotidien euh
après ils sont des cours d'anglais
quotidiens aussi euh surtout en fait
c'est un c'est un cadrement qui est très
très professionnel on a des des
entraîneurs qui sont diplômés niveau fa
Faaa FAA pro qui sont d'ailleurs des
enchant footballeurs professionnels donc
des les structures très très très bien
et très professionnel beaucoup
d'exigen et le projet en fait c'est
mélange un peu les côtés français avec
les culture écossais pour faire un vrai
mélange footballistique cette grande
aventure a débuté ce mardi 12 juillet au
centre technique de Clairefontaine en
Yveline avec le premier rassemblement
des joueurs détectés par les scos de la
structure cette année ils sont une
soixantaine de sportifs venus de France
de Suisse et de Belgique à participer au
programme on dirait une petite famille
et à la fois on apprend l'anglais on
progresse donc c'est scolaire plus le
foot qui est ma passion et partir à
l'étranger donc voilà c'est parfait
c'est l'expérience de pouvoir vivre un
an à l'étranger déjà qui est assez
important en plus de ça les Français on
n'est pas très bon en langue donc
l'opportunité d'apprendre l'anglais dans
un pays anglophone c'est plutôt plutôt
intéressant et puis il y a toujours le
côté foot qui est notre passion donc ça
permet à côté de ça de
pouvoir pouvoir jouer notre passion quoi
les joueurs rejoindront l'Écosse début
septembre pour débuter le championnat
lors de la saison 2015-26 trois joueurs
de l' Académy ont signé un contrat
professionnel avec des clubs
écossais